i'm going to be making homemade
papridella
how do you say it papardelle pappardelle
papra dele
papadele my dad's going to kill me if he
sees this
every viewer from italy i sincerely
apologize
hi guys i'm matt a tasty producer and
since it's the holiday season it means
it's the perfect time of year to show
loved ones that you care about them
which usually means
gifts but that can get pretty expensive
so today i've been challenged to make a
short rib date night dinner for my
girlfriend
for only twelve dollars fingers crossed
this is going to be a bit of a stretch
no romantic dinner is complete without a
show-stopping dessert and liz
loves sweets so i retooled the budget a
little bit in order to make a cannoli
inspired crepe cake
i'm starting with my dry ingredients so
in a large bowl i'm combining flour
and then just a little pinch of salt and
get that all
nice and combined now i'm moving on to
my wet ingredients in a bowl i'm going
to combine my eggs
and i'm just going to give these a
little whisk to break them up a bit and
then i'm adding my evaporated milk
and i'm using evaporated milk because in
recipes like this you don't need a lot
and it's less expensive than a half
gallon of milk
and finally add my water and just give
that all a good whisk until nice and
combined
and now that's set i'm just gonna add my
wet back to my flour
and just whisk until all of that is nice
and combined i'm adding my butter which
is one of my pantry staples
give that all a nice mix i'm going to
let my batter rest for about 30 minutes
and then move on to the next step
while our crepe batter is resting we're
going to use our down time to make some
chocolate garnishes for the top of our
cake i've taken some chocolate chips
here and just melted them in the
microwave and transferred them to a
piping bag and now i'm just going to
pipe out some swirls
admittedly these do look a little rustic
but i'm not a chocolatier liz isn't
dating me because i'm an artist
so i'm fine with how they are we're just
gonna pop them in the freezer
let's get started on our crepes my
batter is ready to go and i have a pan
preheated over medium heat we're just
gonna take a little bit of batter
about two ounces here and then i'm going
to take the pan and just rotate it out
to the edges just so all of your crepes
look uniform and when you stack your
cake
everything looks perfect and i've got
some bubbles forming on the top a nice
crispy edge which means it's time to
flip
get my spatula under there and
look at that oh that's perfect i feel
great right now i haven't made a crepe
in years
sneak this guy off of here lay on the
side to just cool and i'm going to carry
on with my other crepes i think i have
about 20 more to make
just because you save a lot of money
doesn't mean you save a lot of time
that's my last crepe
i have two bowls of whipped topping here
and i'm just going to add some chocolate
that i put in the microwave for about 20
seconds
and now we're just going to gently fold
it in so we don't knock all the air out
of it and cause it to deflate
and i've been able to use the chocolate
chips twice today which means i get more
bang for my buck
i love saving money and you can see the
color starting to change my whipped
topping is all set which means it's time
to assemble
and i'm just going to take a little bit
of my white whipped topping and apply it
to the bottom
this is just going to act as a glue for
my crepes to stick
first one down beautiful take a little
bit of the chocolate whipped topping
dollop that on top and just spread it
out nicely
you want to get to the edges of it we
don't want
any bit of crepe left uncovered take my
second crepe put her on top
take an equal amount of our white
whipped topping up and just spread it
out
and we're just going to repeat that
until we've done it with
all of our crepes so this will be a
minute what's going to happen is as we
stack this you're going to see
each of the individual layers here we go
our last one this has been a climb
and now i'm just going to take the last
of my whipped topping and really pile it
on there
this is going to be the crown to our
crepe cake and i know we called this a
cannoli inspired crepe cake but
we didn't have it in the budget for
ricotta so heavy emphasis on
inspired so in order to keep with the
cannoli theme i'm adding whipped topping
to the top
and then some chocolate chips i'm just
smoothing it out
not too flat you want some nice
dimension on there really want to make
this nice and perfect because this is
the part
everyone's going to be able to see and
that looks like a nice puffy cloud right
there
and then i have some mini chocolate
chips here which i'm just going to
sprinkle all over the top
and we've actually used our chocolate
chips three times in this recipe so
we've really really stretched our dollar
here and finally it's time to top with
our beautiful little chocolate garnishes
look at that that's cute that doesn't
look like it was made on a budget
it costs less than five dollars and
hopefully liz likes it
so let's move on to our main course
so it's time for the main event we're
going to be making a short rib ragu with
handmade pasta now i'm going to start
with my ragu
we have short ribs here now short ribs
are a notoriously expensive ingredient
but i recommend you go to the butcher
counter at your local market
you don't have to buy the set amount in
the prepackaged container so you can
pick and choose exactly what you want
depending on your budget
first thing i'll do is season my short
ribs and it's really important to season
now
because you won't have another
opportunity to season your short ribs
after this
a little bit of pepper i'm going to flip
these over and repeat on the other side
and a good tip is to get boneless short
ribs when you buy it with the bone in
the bone counts towards the weight
you don't want to pay for that i'm just
going to place them in my pan
and at this point you may be tempted to
touch them to move them around
let them sit really let them develop
that color and that browning on the
outside
then you can go ahead and flip them oh
yeah
look at that nice and brown and crispy
i'm just going to repeat that on all
sides and then remove them from the pan
beautiful boom look at that
it's time to add our vegetables so i'm
adding onion carrots
and finally a little bit of garlic and
usually you would add
celery to this it wasn't in the budget
and personally i'm not a huge fan of
celery so we're going to stop there and
just stir
that get it all nice and coated in our
fat and oil
season with a little salt and we're just
gonna let all this go until
nice and softened we're going to add
balsamic vinegar now this is to deglaze
our pan to get all those brown bits off
the bottom
usually you use something like wine but
it wasn't really in the budget for us
this is a great alternative
it's time to add our beef stock and then
our tomatoes
nice stir make sure everyone has gotten
to know each other
add back our short rib so we're going to
let this come to a boil then we're going
to cover and simmer for two hours
and now for my favorite part we're gonna
get started on our pasta
i am the most excited for this step
because i get to make pasta from scratch
now dried pasta is usually pretty cheap
at the store like a buck a box
handmade pasta tends to be a bit more
expensive so i'm going to make it myself
and save a little bit of money so today
i'm going to be making
fresh papridele to get started we're
going to take our flour
and just pour it on our work surface and
then i'm just going to take a little bit
of salt and add it to the top
now it's time to make a well in our
flour and i actually like using a
measuring cup
i have three egg yolks in a bowl here to
which i'm going to add
one whole egg and a little bit of olive
oil and just give that a good little
whisk make sure all of your yolk and
white are nice and combined
now we can add our egg mixture to our
flour at this point i'm going to take my
fork
and slowly start incorporating the flour
and the egg
and take your time you don't want any
leeks to happen you want to gradually
mix everything together
i've been doing this since i was a kid
my dad has been making pasta with me
since i was little
it was kind of a rite of passage in my
house and we're just mixing these
together gradually so the flour
incorporates evenly
and so we don't end up with a lumpy
dough we're just going to take our
scraper and start
incorporating everything together and
now i'm just going to take my hands and
slowly start working this together
and this is where the muscle really
starts coming in at this point
my dough is pretty much come together
and i'm just gonna start working it and
kneading it
and i like to rotate 90 degrees go and
press
and we're going to keep doing this until
the dough ball is nice and smooth on the
outside
you know your dough is nice and done
when it's smooth on the outside
and if you take your finger and just
gently press and it springs
right back into place at this point
we're going to take some plastic wrap
cover our dough up so it doesn't dry out
and we're going to let this rest for 30
minutes and then we'll be back
the dough is nice and rested it's ready
to work with so let's make some
papridele
and just cut this into four equal pieces
save three just cover in some plastic
wrap just press it out a little bit so
it's not too thick
take a little bit of flour not too much
you don't want to dry your pasta out
and apply a little bit to your rolling
pin and then a good trick
to keeping the shape uniform take your
dough rotate it 90 degrees
and then fold it across in thirds and as
you can see the shape is a lot more
uniform than it was before
and i'm just going to continue rolling
out my dough rotating at 90 degrees
really trying to keep that shape nice
and even and you know your pasta is the
ideal thinness if you can see your
fingers underneath it's a little bit
translucent now it's time to cut our
noodles fold the bottom half
halfway up top half down
and then fold each of those in half like
a little envelope of pasta
and the reason we're going with
papridelli is their thick noodles
they're sturdy and they're really going
to grab onto all that sauce we don't
want to go too thick i'm going
maybe a half inch if you grab it it
should unfold
quite nicely you got yourself some pasta
toss with a little bit of flour just to
prevent stickage we'll grab a baking
sheet
just pop those on there i'm just going
to repeat with our remaining dough and
then it's time to bring the whole
dish together i've got a pot here with
salted water at a boil
to which we're going to add our pasta
and because this is
fresh pasta this only needs to cook for
about one to two minutes until it's done
all right so my ragu has been simmering
for a few hours i've got my short rib
all shredded up
and that's why we went with a ragu it
gives you more bang for your buck
it doesn't require as much meat but
still allows you to showcase that short
rib
my pasta is floating at this point which
means we are good to go
don't worry about draining off all the
excess water it's actually good for our
sauce
these look so nice they're like ribbons
i'm just going to plate this together
and then it's time to show liz
hopefully she likes it
everything is nice and plated it looks
fantastic i even went as far as to pour
some champagnes
so let's have liz try it hi oh
good oh my god there's dessert yeah what
do you think
i mean it looks very fancy i have
prepared for us today a homemade short
rib ragu with handmade papridele
and then we have a cannoli inspired
crepe cake do you want to give this a
try
yes let's do it let's dig in well
it's very good can i keep eating or do i
have to stop
you can do that you can keep eating so
are you ready to try dessert
yes it's really good
i want to eat 10 of them all right liz
so we have a short rib ragu and a crepe
cake
how much do you think all of this cost
altogether 30.35
this actually cost 12 and 30 cents to
make
what yeah how that's the spirit of
dollar dish we get the best deals
so that means that you can make this
like all the time you shouldn't have
told me how much it cost
fine fine i can make it more so can i
eat the rest of the stuff
absolutely we're gonna finish our date
night let us know what you think in the
comments below or
let us know what you're making a loved
one this holiday and until then
take care bye guys oh
[Music]
yes
[Music]
you